joining us now texas lieutenant governor
dan patrick dan late tonight a u.s
official confirmed to the ap that the
number of unaccompanied children
uh picked up by border authorities will
likely hit the all-time
high in july why is
this not being covered yeah
going back well it's not being covered
because of the marxist stream
media not mainstream media laura fox is
the only one telling the story and
americans all over this country ought to
be damn
angry what's happening to their country
total invasion
and people in every state are going to
die
through a combination of people coming
in illegally
with covid with the fentanyl drugs or
setting an all-time record and the
criminals that are crossing the border
imagine laura if you lived in mission or
la jolla or westlake i've been down to
all those towns many times
and at two o'clock in the morning and
three o'clock in the morning you have
people milling all around your streets
walking by your house
these people are everywhere when they
leave that bridge lar where do they go
they get on a bus and go to some city in
america taking coven
their crime background if they are
criminals or delivering drugs
this administration is putting american
lives
not at risk not likely to die americans
will die
because of this policy but he's getting
the bipartisan infrastructure thing
through so that'll
that'll help his popularity by the way
that's senator laura that you
interviewed he's he's the kind of
senator that makes republicans not want
to show up at the polls disgraceful
senator cassidy well he came on the show
we couldn't get pretty much anyone to
come on the show to defend this so i
give him credit for dude
man uh watch the media cover by the way
for the uh
this as you said dan this public health
crisis that
the biden administration has created
watch
right now a lot of immigrants are in
very overcrowded shelters detention
centers
and in order to move them out whether
that's to go live with their families
or to go to other detention centers they
need to be able to put them
on buses this is very common it is not
new to the biden administration
immigrants have been transported out of
the state of texas
throughout many administrations oh this
is just
this happens all the time dan this is
always done this way
is she kidding me yeah yeah no
they think the american public is stupid
i can tell you what's going to happen in
the rio grande valley that rio grande
valley that trump turned seven
counties for the first time ever from
democrats republican
he's going to not he but in the 22
elections
when all of us are up governor abbott
myself the statewides and congressmen
we're going to turn that whole valley
republican
hispanics across this country that we've
always said share our values pro-life
for charter schools lower taxes economic
opportunities second amendment rights
and border security hispanics in this
country
are going to be i think the leaders to
throw the democrats out on the rear end
for good
these socialist policies are what many
of them uh escape from and remember
laura if you took your family to cabo
or canku this weekend you couldn't get
back in the country unless you tested
oh no no the border's closed but these
people come in now with
you know no mass no cash no nothing no
yeah the secretary said the borders
closed dan it's closed
that was close to you all right dan
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else